my producer has been getting a lot of  these videos he wants me to react to the  new great scourge affecting america  fat phobia hey bestie  oh gosh you're wrong  i think it's time for another adult  pre-k lesson what do you think  catch a bubble in your mouth  having a preference  is something like i'm looking for a  partner who likes kayaking or wakes up  early in the morning if you lump all fat  people in one group together as though  they are not  very different individuals that's fat  phobic her claim of course is that if  you're not attracted to fat people that  you're a bigot if you're not attracted  to any group then your preference ceases  to be a preference  now i don't quite understand that  illogic there it would still be a  preference it's just a preference she  doesn't like